reid
is with us in richland washington hey
reed welcome to the dave ramsey show
gentlemen thanks for taking my call
today sure man what's up
so i'm 35 my wife's 33
have three kids eight three and one
um basically to try to sum it up bought
our first home
about ten years ago it was a duplex
rental property type of
property lived in one side rent rented
the other out
i'm kind of a fixer-upper sweat equity
entrepreneurial type
person saw an opportunity at another
cheap property
after we were in the duplex for about
five or six years
bob this other house picked it up and
recently with the high market we was
able to sell it for a pretty substantial
profit
and move back into our duplex
after selling another property if that
makes sense yeah how many kids you got
how many kids you got three kids
and when you said when you uh started
all this stuff you did did you have kids
when you started all the stuff no he did
not he did not
so moving back in the duplex wasn't as
fun as you thought it might have been
it's cozier it's cozier um that's not
good
but i have a yeah i have an awesome wife
though and she
she does above and beyond um during that
time me and my wife also have completed
her bachelor's degrees online
while i worked full time and she's
taking care of kids
so great it's been a process
in yeah so we still have a remaining
mortgage balance on the duplex of around
100
000 is what we owe left on it if that
okay hundred thousand let's round it
up um we sold the other property
netted a profit after realtor fees after
everything of about 147
000 and so we already have some money
set aside that's been our
i guess you'd call it emergency fund
it's about three to five months
worth of savings um
we did say things a little bit backwards
we only incurred a little bit of school
debt while
me working full-time and taking care of
children of about twenty thousand
yeah what's your question degrees well
my question is with 147 000 um
we're looking at possibly you know
obviously finding another primary
residence in the future
we could take 100 of that 147 000
pay off the rest of the duplex that is
going to maintain a rental property for
us for
a long time is how i see it
and have some money left over to put
down as a down payment on the next
property
i guess my question is is it worthwhile
to just pay off the rental property
or because it's going to be a rental
property would it behoove me to
um buy something else with as much
contrary to what you've been doing for
your entire life
what we have found is that the people
who build wealth are the ones that get
out of debt and stay out of debt that is
the shortest path
to wealth building it's not keeping
around debt
and or figuring out that some debt is
good and some debt is bad and all that
bull crap
okay so bottom line is is if if i'm you
my goal is to take every dollar i can
get my hands on
and have a paid for house and i paid for
everything
as soon as possible now if that means
keeping the duplex so it takes a few
years to pay off the house or a few
years to pay off the duplex because you
put 147 000
on the house that's fine or if it means
i'm selling the duplex taking the equity
out of it
putting it with the 147 yep paying cash
for a house
then i'm going to start saving to pay
cash for my next rental
and avoiding debt from this point
forward either one of those plans will
work for me
that's exactly right and reid you are
hearing from a man that i know
of that owns the most real estate
possible i i know dave i know it's hard
for real estate i know his passion for
it
but i also know his philosophy and that
means with cash
and so in this and i read i hear it in
you you you got the propensity for some
stupid
uh that going on meaning and as far as
jumping out and grabbing more property
and more and this and that
you said you like getting your hands on
things and working on it what i want you
to do is get your hands on your future
and like dave said one or two ways
either hold on to the duplex
and that's going to be the slowest route
i'm going to microwave this bad boy i'm
going to sell the duplex
and take that money along with the money
you have saved get in a home
cash and pay cash for this thing and now
moving forward i'm not doing
anything debt related i don't care
who it's from how good of an idea or how
great of a property is
if i don't have cash there's no chance
of me taking that risk
so period i did that myself
when i was 28 years old i went broke
first thing we did was we rented for two
years and then we saved up and we paid
cash for a house
um then i saved up paid cash for my
first rental
that go round now i had four million
dollars with real estate before i went
broke
but it was all leveraged and i lost it
all right but my first rental
was about 32 years old and when you have
a paid for rental
and you do not have a house payment and
you start making just a little bit of
money
and you get to keep it all except the
dadgum government's part
right but the rest of it is yours you're
not sending a bunch of it to a bank
it does not take long to buy the next
rental and by the way both of those
rentals for cash then cash flow like
crazy
and that cash starts piling up you get a
snowball going here
in your favor rental snowball rent rates
i mean i got so much rent coming in
nowadays that i can buy another piece of
property
once a month right from the rent that's
coming in but how many properties did
you had
before you would it all fell in at the
height of your real estate back in the
day
well i've owned over 2 000 in my life
but i'm trying to think that
the uh i probably owned uh probably
owned about a hundred
a hundred yeah so you went from i lost
them all to zero
i lost them all yeah yeah or sold them
all to keep from losing from
the two but i mean they all went in that
deal when i got turned up on my
face out of my own stupidity because i
had the propensity which you said the
propensity for stupidity and i
i i did it with zeros on the end man i
don't i don't do anything half butt and
when i do stupid i even go wide open you
know so
um that's what i did so it took
the the second go-round was not the hair
the second go around was the tortoise
that's right
yeah and that's what we're talking about
reed is what we're describing to you is
making your hair curl because
you're just like oh god that sounds so
slow
it is yup it's also the wisest route
it's also the shortest route
the best way to get rich quick is get
rich slow